so I have a very important and
interesting video on how to get rid of
this Dental plaque tartar situation that
you might have I did a video on this
before but it wasn't fully complete so
this would be like a part two because
there's something very very important to
add to this formula to get rid of plaque
okay and this involves vitamin C now we
have the vitamin C complex that in
nature comes with a lot of different
things
one being a part of the vitamin C
complex called ascorbic acid and many
times you'll see vitamin C is ascorbic
acid but it's really not it's just a
part of the vitamin C complex however
you can use ascorbic acid in helping get
rid of plaque but I want to First give
you some background on vitamin C in
relationship to oral health now you've
probably heard of scurvy which is a
severe vitamin C deficiency and all the
different effects that can be created
Sailors at one time developed scurvy and
they had a lot of problems because they
basically were lacking any food with
vitamin C and then over time they found
that you can give a sailor limes lemons
onions even potatoes to supply the
vitamin C and that seemed to cure
skirting so what is it about this
vitamin that is so important well if you
don't have enough vitamin C you cannot
make collagen okay vitamin C is
essential to make collagen and I'm
talking about collagen in your skin in
your bone tissue including your teeth in
your ligaments in your tendons in your
muscles in your joints in all of your
arteries including the capillaries so
when you don't have enough vitamin C for
example in your capillaries you get
blood going through the capillary wall
creating bleeding and so one of the big
indicators to know that your vitamin C
deficient is when you get bleeding gums
anything like gingivitis or a
periodontal disease is usually related
in some way to a vitamin C deficiency
now you probably already know that sugar
is bad for your teeth and gums and so
the sugar then feeds the bacteria that
develop acids that cause cavities
inflamed gum tissue and plucking and
tartar
so what actually is tartar tartar is
biofilms okay what's a biofilm biofilms
are colonies of microbes that have band
together and they develop these calcium
igloos or shelters to hide from your
immune system so in nature like 90 to 95
percent of all these bacterias start to
form biofilms in fact if you were to
walk through a little stream for example
you notice if you step on a rock it's
very slippery there's slime that's the
formation of biofilms so in nature one
of the defense mechanisms that these
microbes use is these kind of a
protective shell and so biofilms form
tartar in your teeth they form the
plaquing in your arteries also they form
these calcium deposits in your joints so
biofilms are around us everywhere and I
do want to touch on the relationship
between vitamin C and biofilms in just
second but first let me just complete my
thought on vitamin C and its function in
your body without vitamin C you actually
get really bad breath okay because you
have this overgrowth of bacteria vitamin
C suppresses pathogens including viruses
bacteria yeast fungus mold and of course
biofilms vitamin C also helps to act as
an antihistamine so in the body when you
have histamines it's related to
allergies and this is why vitamin C is
good to take is to reduce the sneezing
the runny nose the mucus production so
vitamin C as I already mentioned is
involved an essential in generating and
making connective tissue and collagen
vitamin C also tends to make active
folate so in the pre-inactive form of
folic acid that converts into folate
vitamin C is necessary vitamin C is also
a necessary in converting cholesterol
into bile salts it in converting
tryptophan into serotonin in converting
dopamine into epinephrine so there's a
lot of neurotransmitter type functions
that vitamin C is involved with also
making adrenal hormone steroids like
cortisol you need Vitamin C and as you
already know vitamin C is very important
in fighting off an infection and
decreasing the duration of how long you
get an infection and also increasing
your resistance to infection when you're
low in vitamin C you're susceptible to
getting biofilms okay so another
interesting point about this is that we
know vitamin C saved the sailors but
also there's another problem related to
Sailors that I want to cover which is
actually interesting the ships
developing these things called Barnacles
and these Barnacles underneath the ship
would add tremendous amounts of weight
and resistance when traveling through
the sea and these Barnacles are
basically collections of organisms
um like even like clams and lobster and
even smaller organisms with this calcium
shell so if you have a ship with all
these Barnacles you're going to
basically add like a third more fuel
because of the weight and so there's a
lot of problems and the name that they
assigned to Barnacles would be called
Marine following and so they've tried a
lot of things to get rid of these these
growth of these biofilms they try
different paints with chemicals and of
course all this is very toxic but in
1990 this guy who was a sailor had this
brilliant idea why I was eating a
sandwich with he had this uh Red Hot
Chili Peppers in it and he had this idea
that he said I wonder if these Chili
Peppers would kill off these Barnacles
right well he found out that they did
effectively kill off these
microorganisms so he developed a type of
paint using Chili Peppers right and it
worked great and there's one thing about
Chili Peppers Chili Peppers not only
have certain active compounds that are
going to kill biofilms but Chili Peppers
are very very high in vitamin C and even
one of the byproducts that vitamin C
turns into is hydrogen peroxide which is
another
anti-biofilm chemical in fact your body
even makes hydrogen peroxide to protect
against too many biofilms which is
another interesting point in my first
video I gave you a formula that you can
use when you're brushing your teeth to
help reduce plaquing tartar but I did
not include vitamin C in this formula
okay so I'm going to kind of just
explain what I'm going to recommend the
first ingredient to this new formula
Edition which is only four ingredients
would be to take uh one fourth of a
teaspoon of baking soda and dissolve it
in a half a cup of water okay warm water
dissolve it completely and then add a
fourth of a teaspoon of hydrogen
peroxide three percent okay because
hydrogen peroxide is a great mouthwash
and a very powerful anti-biofilm
compound but then I'm going to recommend
something else a fourth of a teaspoon of
non-GMO ascorbic acid now all you're
going to be doing is you're going to be
brushing your teeth with this
um once a day and you're going to spit
out this material and you're probably
going to have one of the most powerful
anti-biofilm compounds around but I
recommend brushing your teeth all around
inside and outside and then spitting it
out and rinsing out your mouth now you
can also add mints peppermint clove as a
great essential oil to help as well and
so it doesn't taste so bad and it can
leave your breath smelling a little bit
better but on top of that just to
understand What vitamin c does and the
effects of vitamin C deficiency for oral
health is huge you should be consuming
things that are high in vitamin C on a
regular basis and that would include
several Foods Peppers both red peppers
hot peppers mild peppers green peppers
green vegetables okay pretty much all
the green vegetables are low with
vitamin C okay the next thing would be
limes and lemons in your diet realize
that if you're getting lemon juice or a
lime juice in a glass or some container
it's been pasteurized and vitamin C is
very sensitive to oxygen and heat so
there's really little vitamin C unless
you're using an actual lemon or lime and
of course fermented cabbage as
sauerkraut has a ton of vitamin C all
right so now that your more educated in
vitamin C I really want you to
understand the difference between
natural vitamin C complex versus just
the synthetic version of ascorbic acid
this would be very very important for
you to have the full picture so I
created this video and put it up right
here for you check it out